- [Instructor] This, right over here,
is a scratch pad on Khan Academy,
created by Khan Academy
user Charlotte Auen.
And, what you see here, is
a simulation that allows
us to keep sampling from
our gumball machine,
and start approximating
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion.
So, her simulation focuses on
green gumballs, but we talked
about yellow before, and
the yellow gumballs, we said
60% were yellow, so let's
make 60% here green.
And then, let's take samples of ten,
just like we did before.
And then, let's just
start with one sample.
So, we're gonna draw one
sample, and what we wanna show,
is we wanna show the percentages.
Which if the proportion of
each sample, that are green.
So, if we draw that first
sample, notice out of the ten,
five ended up being green,
and then it plotted that right
over here, under 50%.
We have one situation where
50% were green, now let's do
another sample, so this
sample 60% are green.
And so, let's keep going.
Let's draw another sample.
And now that one, we have,
we have 50% are green,
and so notice now we see
here on this distribution;
two of them had 50% green.
Now, we could keep drawing samples,
and let's just really increase.
So, we're gonna do 50
samples of ten at a time.
And so, here, we can
quickly get to a fairly
large number of samples.
So here, we're over a thousand samples.
And, what's interesting here,
is we're seeing experimentally,
that our sample;
the mean of our sample proportion here,
is zero point six two.
What we calculated, a few
minutes ago, was that it should
be zero point six.
We also see that the standard
deviation of our sample
proportion, is zero point one six.
And what we calculated was approximately
zero point one five.
And as we draw more and more
samples, we should get even
closer, and closer to those values.
And, we see that, for the most
part, we are getting closer,
and closer, in fact,
now that it's rounded,
we are at exactly those values,
that we had calculated before.
Now, one interesting thing to observe is,
when your population proportion
is not too close to zero,
and not too close to one,
this looks pretty close
to a normal distribution.
And that makes sense.
Because, we saw the relation
between the sampling
distribution of the sample proportion,
and a binomial random variable.
But, what if our population
proportion is closer to zero?
So, let's say our population
proportion is ten percent.
Zero point one.
What do you think the
distribution is going
to look like then?
Well, we know that the mean
of our sampling distribution
is going to be ten percent,
and so you could imagine
that the distribution is
going to be right skewed.
But, let's actually see that.
So, here we see that our distribution
is indeed, right skewed.
And that makes sense.
Because, you can only get
values from zero to one,
and if your mean is closer
to zero, then you're gonna
see the meat of your distribution
here, and then you're
gonna see a long tail to the right.
Which creates that right skew.
And, if your population
proportion was close to one,
well, you can imagine the
opposite is going to happen.
You're going to end up with a left skew.
And, we indeed, see right
over here, a left skew.
Now, the other interesting
thing to appreciate is,
the larger your samples, the
smaller the standard deviation.
And so, let's do a population proportion
that is right in-between.
And so, here, this is similar
to what we saw before,
this is looking roughly normal.
But now, and that's when
we had sample size of ten,
but, what if we have a
sample size of 50 every time?
Well, notice, now it looks like
a much tighter distribution.
This isn't even going
all the way to one yet,
but it is a much tighter distribution.
And, the reason why that made
sense, the standard deviation
of your sample proportion,
it is inversely proportional
to the square root of "n".
And, so, that makes sense.
So, hopefully you have a good
intuition now, for the sample
proportion, it's distribution,
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion
that you can calculate it's
mean, and its' standard deviation.
And you feel good about it,
because we saw it in a simulation.